hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live es ist die wichtigste Wahl in
diesem Jahr in Europa es ist eine Wahl
die über das Schicksal des Landes
entscheiden wird das liest und hört man
aktuell wenn es um die Wahl in der
Türkei geht am Wochenende denn am
Sonntag ist es soweit in der Türkei wird
gewählt und wir haben hier ganz aktuelle
Bilder vom Wahlkampfabschluss Recep
Tahir erdogan ist inzwischen seit 20
Jahren an der Macht doch tatsächlich in
diesem Jahr soll es ein hauchdünnes
Rennen werden um das Präsidentenamt er
hat einen Gegenkandidaten er hat einen
Kandidaten der die Macht will es ist
Thema
erst wurden ihm wenig Chancen
ausgerechnet dann aber hat er massiv
aufgeholt und die Opposition die
befürchtet dass Erdogan sich mit allen
Mitteln an seiner wacht Macht halten
möchte und hat Sorge dass eben bei der
Wahl auch manipuliert werden könnte und
das ist heute Thema bei uns macht er
halt durch Manipulation darüber wollen
wir sprechen ihr könnt Fragen stellen
aktuell mit kommentieren per Mail oder
direkt im Stream denn wir werden im
Laufe dieser Sendung auch mit einem
Wahlbeobachter in der Türkei sprechen
der am Sonntag also als Beobachter im
Einsatz ist aber jetzt zuallererst mit
meiner Kollegin mit einer Feist sie ist
für uns in Istanbul in der Türkei hat
den Wahlkampf in den letzten Tagen
begleitet hallo Anna
hallo Alisa
Anna in der Türkei ist die Lage derzeit
wirklich eher nicht gut eher schlecht es
gibt aktuell herrscht eine der höchsten
Inflationsraten und wir erinnern uns
natürlich auch vor wenigen Wochen ein
ganz furchtbares Erdbeben was Teile des
Landes total
niedergestreckt hat also wirklich
furchtbare desaströse Lage immer noch
dort vor Ort würdest du uns mal die
Stimmung unter diesen schwierigen
Bedingungen jetzt ganz aktuell im
Wahlkampf beschreiben
ja die Stimmung ist gespalten da ist
einerseits Erdogan und seine Anhänger
und Erdogan wird im Wahlkampf nicht müde
zu betonen dass die Opposition dass das
alles Terroristen sein er zündet er
führt Ängste und erst heute früh zum
Beispiel hat er getwittert wenn es nötig
ist werden wir wie in der Nacht des 15
juli auf Kosten unseres Lebens unsere
Unabhängigkeit und Zukunft verteidigen
er bezieht sich da auf den Putschversuch
von 2016 und dieses Zitat oder dieser
Tweet zeigt schon ein bisschen seine
Angst die er tatsächlich hat oder haben
könnte dass er tatsächlich um seine
Macht bankt ob es noch einmal reicht um
der nächste Präsident oder um Präsident
der Türkei zu bleiben und auf der
anderen Seite ist mit seinen Anhängern
im Wahlkampf viel beschwichtigen da viel
ruhiger er betont in jeder Rede dass er
die Türkei zur Demokratie zurückführen
wollte dass er die Korruption bekämpfen
wolle und insofern ist es hier eine
gespaltene Stimmung einerseits hoffnungs
voll andererseits angeheizt das heißt es
soll ein enges Rennen ein Kopf an Kopf
Rennen werden das bedeutet aber
natürlich zeitgleich trotzdem die
Zustimmung für erdogan ist ja da die ist
ja trotzdem groß natürlich woran liegt
das womit punktet Erdogan
ja Erdogan gilt für viele immer noch als
Führungsperson als Krisenmanager im
Wahlkampf hat er viele Versprechen
gemacht er hat ja viele Versprechen
gemacht und hat er viele Geschenke
gemacht einerseits hat er den
Mindestlohn erhöht er hat die
Mindestrente erholt er hat ein Monat Gas
gratis für alle Türken ausgegeben jeden
Tag gefühlt hat er ein neues Großprojekt
eröffnet er hat zum Beispiel das erste
türkische Gasfeld eingeweiht er hat das
erste türkische Atomkraftwerk eingeweiht
er hat einen Amphibien Schiff von dem
kampfdrohen starten können eröffnet und
zeigt natürlich er ist ein großer
starker Mann der die Nation weiter groß
macht und eben mitspielen lässt unter
den Weltmächten und das zieht dieses
Jahr kommt ja noch was spannendes dazu
es werden zum ersten Mal über 5
Millionen Menschen werden zum ersten Mal
wählen also ganz viele Jungen
Wählerinnen und Wähler sind dabei das
sind rund acht Prozent der
Wahlberechtigten könnten die denn den
Unterschied machen also wozu tendiert
diese Gruppe weiß man da irgendwas aus
Umfragen vorher
ja es ist ganz lange dass diese
Jungwähler dieser Erstwähler wohl Kemal
College der Rollo ihre Stimmen geben
werden mittlerweile gibt es aber auch
Studien die sagen das wohl 30 bis 35%
Erdogan wählen könnten bei Umfragen auf
der Straße die wir gemacht haben bei
Nachfragen bei jungen Leuten kam
tatsächlich raus dass es etliche junge
Leute gibt die Erdogan eben auch immer
noch als Führungsperson sehen und
schätzen und ihm auch verzeihen dass die
Wirtschaft die Situation wie sie im
Moment ist im Land so ist wie sie ist
und wir haben schon angesprochen das ist
ja natürlich total interessant dass
jetzt Kilic der volo so aufholen konnte
oder grundsätzlich so viele mobilisiert
hat so gut da steht jetzt das ist
tatsächlich also ein hauchtendes Rennen
werden soll Erdogan er es vielleicht das
schafft was als langer als Unmöglichkeit
Erdogan ablösen nach 20 Jahren wie viel
woher hat er diesen Zuspruch also was
verspricht er woher kommt der
am besten kann man es vielleicht sehen
wenn man sich ein Video anschaut was
Kemal Kilic daole produziert hat und auf
Twitter ausgestrahlt hat da posiert er
mit einer Zwiebel es ist ein ganz
profanes Video eben er mit dieser
Zwiebel und er argumentiert dass wenn er
nicht an die Macht komme werde der
zwiebelpreis weiter steigen dieses Video
wurde aufgenommen in seiner Küche und
ging hier in der Türkei tatsächlich
viral und es steht für diesen ein
bisschen für diesen Mann der eben sehr
ein sehr ruhigen Wahlkampf macht und ähm
ganz anders sich gibt als Erdogan
schauen wir uns mal zusammen einen
Beitrag an um ein bisschen zu verstehen
wie die Situation aktuell in der Türkei
ist denn Erdogan was er getan hat in den
letzten 20 Jahren ist schon das Land
umzubauen alle Macht auf sich selbst zu
konzentrieren schauen wir rein in einen
erklärt Beitrag von Jochen Spieß
Präsident Recep Tayyip Erdogan hat zehn
Jahre lang einen grundlegenden Umbau der
politischen Strukturen betrieben von
einer parlamentarischen Demokratie hin
zu einem strikten Präsidialsystem der
Beginn lag in Krisenzeiten
2013 gab es größere Proteste im gesipark
von Istanbul 2016 scheiterte der
Putschversuch von Teilen des türkischen
Militärs begleitet von
Massenentlassungen und einer
Verhaftungswelle mutmaßlicher
politischer Gegner
Erdogan initiierte 2017 im offiziellen
Ausnahmezustand des Landes ein
Verfassungsreferendum
51,4% der Türkinnen und Türken stimmten
für die neue Verfassung so lautete das
amtliche Ergebnis des Referendums auch
das Parlament stimmte für die
tiefgreifenden Verfassungsänderungen die
so im Juni 2018 in Kraft traten die
Funktionen des Staats- und
Regierungschefs sind im Präsidentenamt
vereint Erdogan kann seitdem
durchregieren und eigenmächtig
Verordnungen erlassen die das Parlament
nur mit einem eigenen Gesetz wieder
aufheben kann doch der Präsident könnte
dann das Parlament auflösen und
Neuwahlen ausrufen sogar manche Richter
kann der türkische Präsident benennen
Justiz hat ihre Unabhängigkeit
weitgehend verloren die meinungs- und
pressefreiheit ist schon länger massiv
eingeschränkt die neue Verfassung gilt
seit knapp fünf Jahren der jetzige
Wahltermin wurde vorgezogen sodass
Erdogans reguläre Amtszeit noch nicht
ganz vorbei ist so sieht er sich im
Recht im neuen Präsidialsystem zum
dritten Mal zur Wahl anzutreten
eigentlich sind in der Türkei nur zwei
präsidiale Amtszeiten vorgesehen
viele sprechen in dem Zusammenhang mit
der Wahl von einer Schicksalswahl welche
Befürchtungen gibt es denn wenn das
Schicksal also entscheidet wenn Erdogan
bleibt weil so wird das ja auch
verstanden und gewertet dass das jetzt
über das Schicksal des Landes
entscheiden könnte
ja viele befürchten dass es noch
autokratischer werden könnte wenn wir
uns jetzt mal einen Bereich rauspicken
zum Beispiel die Frauenrechte da ist es
so dass Erdogan vor zwei Jahren z.B aus
der istanbul-konvention ausgetreten ist
zum Schutz der Frau von häuslichen
Gewalt und nun steht eins der letzten
verbleibenden wichtigsten Gesetze die
die Frauen vor häuslicher Gewalt schützt
eben auf der Kippe weil er waren um sich
herum ein Bündnis geschmiegt hat aus
extrem
nationalistischen
islamistischen und ultra konservativen
Kräften und es wird eben befürchtet dass
im Bereich Frauenrechte im Bereich der
Rechte für lgbtq die Erdogan in seinen
Reden als Hauptfeind aus erkoren hat das
ist da massiver Einschränkungen geben
könnte
Anna zum Schluss noch eine user-frage
die ich gesehen habe da hatte einen User
eine Userin zunächst mal geschrieben
wird Erdogan im unwahrscheinlichen Fall
also der oder die Userin geht gar nicht
davon aus dass er verliert wird Erdogan
im unwahrscheinlichen Fall einer
Niederlage diese überhaupt anerkennen
was sind das was gibt es dafür Vermutung
ja das ist eine gute Frage die in diesen
Tagen hier natürlich eine große Rolle
spielt es wird vermutet dass sollte das
Bündnis Kemal Kilic Derulo
50,50,x Prozent also sehr knapp gewinnen
dass dann die andere Seite also das
Bündnis um Erdogan herum dass die dieses
Ergebnis vor Gericht anfechten werden
auf der anderen Seite könnte es
natürlich genauso laufen das sollte
Erdogan mit 50 x Prozent gewinnen das
eben dann auch das Bündnis um Kemal
College da Rollo dieses Ergebnis
anfechten wird
danke für deine Einschätzung heute abend
andernfalls war das für uns live in der
Türkei
vielen Dank
und eine die erlebt hat was es bedeutet
wenn Erdogans macht Apparat zuschlägt
das ist Michelle Tulum der Name der ist
einigen von euch vielleicht noch bekannt
da gab es massig Schlagzeilen vor ein
paar Jahren denn vor fast genau sechs
Jahren wurde die Journalistin in der
Türkei mitten in der Nacht festgenommen
wir haben einen Beitrag und dann habe
ich ein Gespräch mit ihr vor dieser
Sendung geführt und wir schauen zusammen
rein einen Beitrag von Beatrice
Steinecke
Ende April 2017 mitten in der Nacht
stürmt eine Anti-Terror-Einheit
bewaffnet mit Maschinenpistolen die
Wohnung von meschalitulu in Istanbul sie
wird auf den Boden gedrückt die Wohnung
auf den Kopf gestellt ihr damals
zweijähriger Sohn sieht wie sie
verhaftet wird die Vorwürfe gegen sie
Terror Propaganda und Mitgliedschaft in
einer Terrororganisation sie arbeitet
als Journalistin und Übersetzerin etwa
für eine Nachrichtenagentur sie ist
deutsche Staatsbürgerin in Ulm geboren
mit kurdischen Wurzeln dennoch über die
Verhaftung werden die deutschen Behörden
nicht wie üblich informiert über Nacht
wird meschale tulu zu einer der
bekanntesten politischen Gefangenen in
der Türkei erst als sie im Gefängnis in
den Hunger streikt tritt darf ihr Vater
sie besuchen und ihr Sohn zeitweise bei
ihr bleiben Oktober 2017 beginnt der
Prozess die Staatsanwaltschaft fordert
15 Jahre Haft
dann rund zwei Monate später
Erleichterung
mesha-tulo wird aus der
Untersuchungshaft entlassen unter
Auflagen
erst als ihre Ausreisesperre im Sommer
2018 aufgehoben wird dürfen sie und ihr
Sohn nach Deutschland zurückkehren das
Verfahren gegen sie läuft weiter
weitere dreieinhalb Jahre dauert es bis
sie vom Gericht in der Türkei frei
gesprochen wird
und meschalotulo ist jetzt bei uns in
der Sendung und wir können mit ihr
sprechen fast acht Monate saßen sie in
der Türkei in Haft wurden Jahre später
erst freigesprochen wir können jetzt
heute über Ihren Fall sprechen schön
dass Sie da sind hallo
ihr Fall gilt als Beweis für die nicht
Rechtsstaatlichkeit in der Türkei und
eben auch für die Einschränkungen der
Pressefreiheit denn es war ja nicht nur
ihr fallen sondern mit Ihnen gemeinsam
waren eben mehrere Kolleginnen und
Kollegen angeklagt auch ihr Ehemann war
mit angeklagt er hatte sich
regierungskritisch bei Twitter geäußert
und diese Willkür damals nicht zu wissen
wie es ausgeht wie es für sie weitergeht
war das das Schlimmste die Hilflosigkeit
ja genau das Ungewisse dass man einfach
nicht wusste was kann ich tun kann ich
überhaupt irgendwas tun und wird es dann
auch hilfreich sein also wenn man weiß
dass die Macht in den Händen anderer
Menschen ist dann ist man einfach ihm
hilflos ausgeliefert und das war glaube
ich einfach das Schlimmste dieser Zeit
und dieses hohe Maß auch ein Willkür wer
wird verhaftet und warum befürchtet
befürchten sie jetzt auch dass es
genauso wie willkürlich zu gehen könnte
rund um die Wahl
ja das ist natürlich schon seit längerem
so dass die Justiz sehr willkürlich aber
vor allem politisch motiviert handelt im
Sinne der Regierung und jetzt um die
Wahlen herum sieht man es jetzt noch mal
ganz deutlich das ganz viele
parteivationäre der oppositionellen
Parteien eben festgenommen werden auch
Auflagen bekommen das einfach die
Repressionen noch mal noch mal
drastischer zugenommen
sie sind im Kontakt mit türkischen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor Ort die
also noch berichten versuchen zu
berichten wie steht es aktuell denn um
die Pressefreiheit in der Türkei
ja die Pressefreiheit ist eigentlich
keine Pressefreiheit in unserem Sinne
wie wir sie kennen denn der Türkei ist
seit dem Putschversuch 2016 wurden ganz
viele Kanäle ganz ganz viele
Nachrichtenagenturen geschlossen
Journalisten inhaftiert
tagtäglich erfahren Sie Repressionen
aber diejenigen die einzelnen die
mutigen die noch dort sind vor Ort sind
und versuchen das Volk zu informieren
die erschaffen sich natürlich Kanäle
über soziale Medien und wollen natürlich
ihre Arbeit fortführen jetzt ist
natürlich noch schlimmer weil auch die
sozialen Medien ständig eine Zero
erleben es kam schon vor das Wetter das
das dritte dem Strom abgedreht wurde
dass man versucht eben verschiedene
Kanäle zu hindern jeden Tag gesperrt so
dass die Menschen eigentlich den Zugriff
den freien Zugriff gar nicht mehr haben
jetzt erwarte ich persönlich natürlich
noch mal das in der Wahlnacht vielleicht
ein paar davor jetzt die Tage noch mal
mehr Zäsur stattfinden kann denn es ist
natürlich so dass die Menschen sich
informieren wollen wissen wollen wie die
Ergebnisse sind und es kann schon sein
dass die Regierung so auf den letzten
Drücker noch mal über Twitter über
Facebook oder andere sozialen Medien
noch mal versucht hier äh großen Druck
aufzubauen und die Journalisten dran
hindert dass sie berichten es gab
natürlich auch wieder Festnahmen da
wurden vor allem in den kurdischen
Gebieten wurden bis zu 20
JournalistInnen
inhaftiert das zeigt doch mal wie die
Regierung versucht eigentlich auch alles
unter Kontrolle zu behalten dass sie
eben nicht berichten von den wahlpro
lokalen dass sie nicht über die
Ergebnisse schreiben und all das ist
halt so eine Vorarbeit die die Regierung
bereits leistet ist das ihre größte
Befürchtung rund um die Wahl also dass
die Pressefreiheit eingeschränkt werden
könnte die Menschen einfach nicht an
Informationen frei und zugänglich
drankommen können oder sind da noch mehr
Befürchtungen die sie haben rund um die
Wahl ja das ist die eine Seite das die
Wahlpropaganda quasi nur einseitig
stattfindet das nur regierungstreue
Wahlpropaganda öffentlich wird und dass
die anderen Oppositionellen Parteien und
Menschen eben hier keine Stimme finden
aber die andere Sache ist natürlich das
ist zu Wahlbetrug kommen kann dass es zu
verschiedenen Aktionen seitens der
Regierung kommen kann um die Wahlen zu
täuschen oder eben
unverhältnisse unverhältnismäßigkeiten
zu machen und da ist natürlich wichtig
dass die Journalisten draufschauen das
dann gleich die Bevölkerung darüber
informieren dass sie eben diese
Information dass sie durch sie hat und
die Befürchtung ist natürlich da dass
die Regierung versuchen wird wieder Wahl
gedruckt
anzuwenden und wenn das nicht öffentlich
gemacht werden kann dann kann es eben
umgehen das machen von daher ist es sehr
wichtig dass wahlbeobachtet vor Ort sind
vor allem internationale Wahl beobachte
aber auch Journalistinnen und
Journalisten darüber berichten können
damit eben alles so möglich sind also so
transparent wie möglich ablaufen kann
wie würde der Aussehen der Wahl Betrug
es gab verschiedene eigentlich bisher
also ich habe 2018 selbst auch eine Wahl
in der Türkei miterlebt und es kommt
eben vor dass im Vorfeld ganze Dörfer
oder
Gruppierungen bestochen werden mit
Materialien also das Lebensmittel mit
Waschmaschinen mit Tiefkühltruhe das
haben wir schon alles gesehen vor allem
in ärmung ärmeren Region es kam vor das
syrische Flüchtlinge
Pässe bekommen haben so dass sie wählen
konnten oder das eben
ganze Säcke voll mit vorgestempelten
Wahlzettel gefunden wurden die dann eben
andere Wahlzettel ersetzen sollten all
das haben wir schon gesehen ähm ich bin
natürlich gespannt was die Regierung
sich jetzt ausgedacht hat ob sie eben
die gleiche Masche ziehen wird oder ob
sie auch andere Ideen noch hat aber das
was ganz besonders wichtig ist ist
natürlich dass wir in zehn Großstädten
Erdbeben hatten und dass die Menschen
ihre Wohnungen verloren haben dass die
gar nicht mehr dort leben und dass sie
alle irgendwie aus
woanders hinreisen mussten zu Familie zu
Freunden ob diese Menschen tatsächlich
noch wählen können ob ihre Stimme auch
hier gehört von finden wird oder ob das
dann wieder ersetzt wird durch
irgendwelche vorgefertigten Wahlzettel
das ist meine größte Befürchtung dass
genau bei diesen Wahlen die Erdbeben
Opfer vielleicht eben nicht nicht
tatsächlich zu weil beitreten kann sie
reisen aktuell nicht mehr in der Türkei
sind seit ihrer Freilassung nicht mehr
eingereist weil sie um ihre Sicherheit
fürchten würde denn der Machtwechsel das
ändern wäre es dann wieder soweit dass
sie sagen würden ich kann wieder in die
Türkei zurück
in meinen leider reicht der Machtwechsel
allein nicht aus um zu sagen ich kann
wieder sicher in die Türkei reisen das
gilt nicht nur für mich sondern für alle
anderen Menschen auch denn die Akademie
hat in den vergangenen 21 Jahren an der
Ämter mit ihrem eigenen regierungsfreien
Menschen gesetzt die wirklich politisch
motiviert im Sinne der AKP gehandelt
haben und jetzt ist es wichtig dass bei
einer eventuellen macht Übergabe
all diese Ente dann auch wieder neu
besetzt und auch demokratische und auch
Gesetzes Treue besetzt dann wäre es
vielleicht wieder möglich für alle
Menschen die in der Türkei politisch
verfolgt wurden auch wieder in das Land
zurück zu reisen aber das wird
wahrscheinlich mehr als nur ein zwei
Jahre dauern aber ich bin zuversichtlich
dass das dann auch klappen wird
sagt Michelle Tolo vielen Dank dass Sie
heute bei uns zu Gast waren
äußert Sorge vor Wahlbetrug ich habe es
auch in den Kommentaren gelesen hier
einer von Jürgen wöhrheide er schreibt
das Problem bei Wahlen in Autokratien
ist Wahlbetrug also wird es schwer dass
Erdogan abgelöst wird ob die Opposition
zusammenhält um zu reagieren ist auch
noch fraglich fragt sich der User und
wir können jetzt über dieses Thema
Wahlbetrug mit einem sprechen der das
Ganze im Blick behalten wird am
Wochenende es ist Frank Schwabe er ist
Bundestagsabgeordneter eigentlich aber
aktuell eben auf spezieller Mission in
der Türkei er leitet dort die
internationale wahlbeobachtungsmission
des Europarates hallo schönen guten
Abend Herr Schwabe
schon gehört auch in unseren Kommentaren
es gibt da also eine Sorge sie sind
jetzt also ganz aktuell in Ankara
bleiben dort auch das ganze Wochenende
über und natürlich auch noch bis zum
Montag in die nächste Woche wir haben
wir uns vielleicht zunächst mal dass wir
das verstehen ihre Arbeit jetzt am
Wochenende vorzustellen was haben sie
genau vor
im Grunde genommen besteht so eine
Wahlbeobachtung aus zwei Teilen das
erste ist sich das Umfeld von Wahlen
anzugucken das heißt wir Monitoren die
Lage in der Türkei schon seit vielen
Jahren und äußern uns auch dazu und dann
geht es um den Wahltag und dort sind wir
mit über 100 Abgeordneten vom Europarat
aber auch der Organisation für
Sicherheit und zusammen mit in Europa
und wir arbeiten zusammen hier
entsprechend vor Ort am Ende noch mit
anderen Beobachtern sind wir am Ende mit
250 Teams vor Ort und sind in ganzen Tag
am Wahlsonntag entsprechend dem Einsatz
von der Öffnung der Wahllokale das ist
nicht anders als in Deutschland auch mit
dem Wahllokal hier bis zu Schließung und
dann geht's natürlich um die Auszählung
und dann werden wir gucken ob das was in
der Wahl oder gelandet ist am Ende auch
wirklich dazu führt dass das Ergebnis
auch am Ende korrekt dargestellt wird
von der Zentralbank
also sie sind dabei beim Prozess des
Wellens in den Wahllokalen dann auch
später beim Auszählen
genau beides geht also los morgen schon
mit der Öffnung der Wahllokale um zu
gucken ob da alles ordentlich abläuft
man kann ja auch vorher schon was im
wahlrohren tun zum Beispiel deswegen
beginnt eine solche Wahlbeobachtung sehr
früh am Morgen man muss früh aufstehen
und am Ende geht es darum zu gucken wenn
die Wahllokale geschlossen werden dann
wird ausgezählt dann sind wir in den
Wahllokalen gucken sie dort ausgezählt
wird und gucken dann wie die
Wahlergebnisse zusammengebracht werden
über lokale
Wahl
Einrichtung also dort Vorstände wo
entsprechend gezählt wird bis am Ende zu
nationalen Ebene wir können das
natürlich nur stichprobenartig tun und
ich habe bei mir schadetology gehört
dass sie sagt sie baut auf die
internationalen Wahl Beobachter aber
auch drauf aber ich war vor allen Dingen
auf die nationalen Wahl beobachtet
werden 100.000 100.000 da muss man sagen
junge Leute die unterwegs sind und
versuchen die Integrität dieses
Wahlvorgang sich herzustellen
ein User eine Userin äußert bei uns
jetzt eine Sorge und zwar schreibt er
oder sie denke dass Erdogan jedes Mittel
auch Fälschung einsetzen wird um an der
Macht zu bleiben er ist kein Demokrat
verlieren für ihn ausgeschlossen was
hören sie aus dem Land welche
Befürchtungen gibt es klingen die
genauso schlimm wie jetzt dieser
Kommentar selbst im Land in der Türkei
ich kann immer nur das berichten was uns
berichtet wird ich bin ja hier neutral
und äußere mich auch gar nicht so sehr
über die einzelnen Parteien aber
natürlich werden an uns Sorgen
herangetragen das ist in der Tat auch
zur Wahlfälschung kommen kann auf der
anderen Seite muss man sagen dass die
Türkei bei Wahlen durchaus sehr erfahren
ist und das ist eine wirklich trotz
aller Schwierigkeiten der letzten Jahre
und Jahrzehnte eine breit gefächerte
Zivilgesellschaft gibt die wirklich sehr
starke Checks und balances eingeführt
hat es wird zum Beispiel parallel
ausgezählt also es gibt eine zentrale
Wahlbehörde die zählt das zusammen was
in den Wahllokalen an Stimmen reinkommt
aber das machen die Parteien parallel
auch Parteien haben mein eigenes
Zielsystem wo Menschen die einen
Wahllokalen sind das wiederum an eine
zentrale Instanz weiterleiten und die
selber eben gucken ob das was ausgezählt
wird vor Ort am Ende auch
dementsprechend was zum Beispiel
zentrale Wahlbehörde dann zusammen
sammelt in Ankara und das ist schon
beeindruckend wie gut die das machen
jetzt ist es eine ganz spezielle
Situation wenn sie schon angesprochen in
dieser Sendung vor einigen Wochen gab es
eben ein schweres Erdbeben in einem
großen Landesteil der Türkei und in der
Provinz ja Mann ist Burak bin seit
zuständig für
1442 Wahlurnen das ist eine ganz schöne
Menge er ist der regionale Vorsitzende
CHP und unsere Kollegin Anna Feist hat
mit ihm gesprochen wir hören mal kurz
gemeinsam in seinen Ton und sprechen
dann über diese Sorgen und Befürchtungen
für das Gebiet
senden das größte Problem sind die die
tot sind Ihre Daten stehen noch im
Wahlregister schon in der Vergangenheit
kam es zu schwerem Wahlbetrug dieses Mal
werden wir das versuchen zu verhindern
indem wir alle Vorsichtsmaßnahmen
treffen
gerade erwähnt also verstorbene Menschen
stehen noch im Wahlregister der Users
wenn Odendahl der oft so sieht hier in
diesem Stream und immer viele Fragen
stellt vielen Dank dafür schreibt bei
Facebook wie wird im Erdbebengebiet
sichergestellt dass keine Toten aus dem
Erdbebengebiet wählen gehen also wählen
gehen schreibt er
ich habe es gerade schon gesagt am Ende
und die GAP die Oppositionspartei die
größte hat ja gerade im Grunde berichtet
die Parteien selber sind in den
Wahllokalen unterwegs das ist wie in
Deutschland auch die Wahlvorstände vor
Ort werden aus verschiedenen Parteien
gebildet wir haben dazu noch eben ganz
viele zivilgesellschaftliche
Wahlbeobachter die zwar nicht in den
Wald vorstellen sind aber Zugang zu den
Wahllokalen haben und die müssen sich
das genau angucken man wird dort hat er
dann die Listen wie auch in Deutschland
wenn man wählen geht und dann wird er
entsprechend abgehakt und dann muss man
eben gucken ist das was da passiert
plausibel aber es gibt Möglichkeiten
oder es gibt Probleme sicherlich vor Ort
wir haben zum Beispiel Situation dass
möglicherweise 3 Millionen Menschen in
den Erdbeben Gebieten Wohlen wollen die
sich nämlich nicht registriert haben
woanders in der Türkei wo es jetzt leben
und die haben nur die Chance dorthin zu
reisen und dort zu wählen und das kann
natürlich dann auch zu sehr schwierigen
infrastrukturellen Voraussetzungen vor
Ort führen wo man vielleicht auch ein
bisschen den über Blick verliert
deswegen noch mal bauen wir auf die
lokalen Wahlbeobachter die nationalen
Wahlbeobachter und wir sind mit ihm vor
Ort und wiederum wären Ergebnisse auch
zusammen und zu dokumentieren aber das
ihrer Meinung nach wahrscheinlich die
größte Herausforderung die
infrastrukturellen Probleme im
Erdbebengebiet das haben sie schon jetzt
rausgehört von den Menschen mit denen
sie gesprochen haben
klar ist das ein Riesenherausforderung
viele der Wahllokale gibt es ja alle
nicht mehr sondern dann müssen jetzt
überhelfs Konstruktionen errichtet
werden und das müssen Millionen Menschen
über wenige Straßen die es gibt dort
entsprechend hingeführt werden
Sven Odendahl hatte noch eine weitere
spannende Frage gestellt und zwar möchte
er wissen eine Klage gegen die
Entscheidung der Wahlbehörde soll ja
nicht möglich sein was passiert wenn die
oecd-wahl Beobachter oder eben auch sie
zum Ergebnis kommen dass die Wahl
unregelmäßig war was passiert dann und
wie würde sich die EU Verhalten gibt es
dann Szenario
naja wir haben ich habe gesagt wir haben
die Situation auf der ganzen Welt das
ist unabhängige Staaten gibt die
entscheidend ist am Ende selber aber
natürlich haben die sich verpflichtet
international zum Beispiel
Wahlbeobachtung ins Land zu lassen und
ähm wenn die obere die die oberste
Wahlbehörde die am Ende erinnert hat
unabhängig ist und nicht überprüft
werden kann
zu einem falschen Ergebnis käme können
wir das nicht revidieren aber wir sind
ja dafür da dann darüber zu reden die
müssen wissen wenn Sie ein falsches
Ergebnis liefern würden dann werden wir
darüber berichten und das wird natürlich
auch in der Türkei zu massieren
Auswirkungen führen und deswegen ist es
so eine Form von Shakes and balances und
dem Versuch eben auch durch Anwesenheit
internationalerweise Beobachtung
sicherzustellen dass alle in den
betreffenden Land eben die Integrität
der Wahlen sicherstellen auch die
Oberbehörde
zum Schluss noch die Frage wann wissen
wir mehr ist das wirklich schon am
Sonntag am Sonntagabend ist es erst der
Montag wann erwarten sie dass man
wirklich von Ergebnissen ausgehen kann
die man dann auch natürlich ganz klar
für für voll nehmen kann
wir wissen natürlich am Ende nicht ob es
dann zu einer Stichwahl kommt nochmal 14
Tage später aber am Sonntag wird man das
spät am Abend ein Gewissen können wie
das Ergebnis ist wir hatten mal das
Szenario bei den Kommunalwahlen in
Istanbul vor ein paar Jahren das
plötzlich eben die Wahlbehörde aufgehört
hat zu zählen sowas darf nicht wieder
vorkommen und deswegen muss zügig
ausgezählt werden und dann wird das
Ergebnis auch am späten Abend eigentlich
schon verstehen sagt Frank Schwabe er
ist als danke danke
so ich schaue noch mal in Eure
Kommentare ich sehe hier von einmal Wolf
Tafel er schreibt hoffe dass Erdogan
nicht wiedergewählt wird denn Erdogan
tritt die Menschenrechte wie auch die
Demokratie mit Füßen klares Nein zum
Erdogan Regime das ist die Meinung bei
Facebook von Wolf Tafel und dann habe
ich noch einen Kommentar bei Youtube
gelesen von einem User einer Userin die
sich Morgenmuffel nennt er oder sie
schreibt ich würde mich für die Türkei
freuen wenn eine demokratische Regierung
wieder das Zepter nimmt es wäre ein
deutlicher Fortschritt für die Türken
findet die Person wir werden das ganze
hier natürlich bei ZDF heute seid ihr da
immer aktuell informiert begleiten das
ganze Wochenende die Wahl in der Türkei
für heute erstmal vielen Dank an euch
für euer Interesse dass ihr dabei wart
und bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]